bien
tras meses de investigación la
estadounidense faisem y la alemana bayón
tec anuncian que su vacuna contra el
coronavirus es eficaz en más de un 90%
la información es recibida con
beneplácito y cautela a la vez
uy hemos superado un obstáculo
importante pero quedan varios antes de
que sepamos que se puede utilizar la
vacuna
acabamos de recibir noticias positivas
en esta lucha con el anuncio de que se
ha avanzado hacia una vacuna exitosa
unos días después la compañía
estadounidense moderna y el instituto
ruso gama leia aseguran que sus vacunas
también tienen una eficacia de más del
90% el 20 de noviembre pzifer ibai un
tec hacen una solicitud de uso de
emergencia al regulador de salud de eeuu
el 30 de noviembre moderna anuncia que
también solicitó a los reguladores el
mismo permiso
el 2 de diciembre de reino unido se
convierte en el primer país occidental
en aprobar una vacuna la de facer y
bayonne tec unos días después una mujer
de 90 años es la primera persona en
recibir
tras meses de secretismo el presidente
ruso vladimir putin anuncia que su país
comenzará un plan masivo de inmunización
con su vacuna sputnik tu presión les
pediría que organizaran el trabajo para
que a fines de la próxima semana hayamos
comenzado esta vacunación a gran escala
pero ante el optimismo generalizado la
o&m se hizo una advertencia progresión
vaccines gibbs a soul leaf el progreso
en las vacunas nos da a todos un impulso
y ahora podemos empezar a ver la luz al
final del túnel sin embargo a la o ms le
preocupa que haya una percepción cada
vez mayor de que la pandemia ha
terminado en este punto la preocupación
ya no es la vacuna en sí misma sino el
acceso para los países en vías de
desarrollo la esperanza para estas
naciones ahora está puesta en kóvacs una
iniciativa internacional que busca una
distribución equitativa
[Música]
en repetidas ocasiones he pedido que la
vacuna kobe 19 sea un bien público
mundial disponible para todos en todas
partes el acelerador act y su iniciativa
kóvacs son las herramientas para
llevarnos allí el 12 de diciembre el
regulador de alimentos y fármacos de
estados unidos dea su visto bueno para
el uso de emergencia de la vacuna de
facer by on dec
un día después una enfermera en nueva
york sería la primera inmunizada
en los días posteriores varios países de
américa latina comienzan con sus planes
de vacunación ecuador y chile son los
primeros en aprobar el proyecto de facer
y beyond tech
el 19 de diciembre la fed aprueba el uso
de la vacuna de moderna y ese mismo día
el vicepresidente saliente mike pence se
inocula la the fighter
[Música]
el 21 de diciembre la comisión europea
da su aval al proyecto de facer beyond
tech y ese mismo día es el presidente
electo de eeuu joe biden quien se vacuna
a la inmunización podrá comenzar a la
misma hora en toda la unión europea el
27 28 y 29 de diciembre esta es una muy
buena manera de terminar este año
difícil y finalmente comenzar a pasar la
página sobre el cob y 19
la vacuna ha llenado de esperanzas al
mundo pero la pandemia mostró aún más
las notorias e inmensas desigualdades de
nuestras sociedades
en la carrera por la vacuna de los
países ricos sean asegurados cientos de
millones de dosis para sus poblaciones y
muy lejos se ve la posibilidad de
inmunizarse para las naciones más pobres
[Música]